welcome back to LED live today we're
gonna talk about some celebrities that
invite spirits into their lives so that
they can do better acting's do you know
which ones do this find out on this
episode of LED live so before we get
into this topic of which celebrities are
using demonic influences to actually
help them in their acting we want to
thank our patreon donors for allowing us
to be able to do what we do
you guys are awesome thanks so much for
your support every show we will thank
you you will probably hear us say this a
million times but thank you thank you
thank you you guys are literally the
reason that keeps the lights on in this
operation so we just thank you guys if
you also want to become a patreon donor
we do post shows often after we do a
particular topic if you guys want a
little bit more detail definitely check
out our patreon x' we also want to share
with you this video is sponsored by
video mission comm it's a Christian
stock media resource check these guys
out and there's a lot of really
high-class video reenactments of
biblical topics if you guys are making
YouTube videos and you need some cool
footage to be able to illustrate those
topics check out video mission comm also
t-shirts we sell t-shirts so you know
it's a great way to support and we're
the witness when people walk around and
go oh I were to get that cool t-shirt
you can see I got it from little lights
studios you should check out their
YouTube page today's topic is going to
be taken from actually a couple of
projects we've worked on one called the
gnostic gospels we made a documentary
that really deals with this the the
movies like The Matrix 300 a lot of
shows Trump and those those kind of
movies that take biblical themes and
flip them upside down also there's
another one called false system of
worship that
one specifically is gonna be taken from
and you can get these on our website
little light studios alright let's get
into this everybody's excited to get
into this we have a guest on our show
again leah has been joining us for the
last couple of episodes and she came out
of the New Age movement into
Christianity we heard her testimony if
you haven't seen it yet definitely check
out some of the other videos in our
YouTube page you'll have here her whole
testimony and then the topic of of the
New Age movement also go to her channel
Leah for the light that's right in the
description Leah for the light you can
subscribe to her channel as well she has
a real passion to share her experience
of really the joy and peace that Christ
has given to her and so we're excited to
have you on the show today I wanted to
do this show with her here because
Hollywood has a lot of connection to the
New Age movement so yeah this might be a
shocker for some of you but hold on to
your seats many of you have probably
heard of Aleister Crowley yes right so I
kind of want to just set the stage with
this if you don't know that much about
Aleister Crowley he's kind of like the
the modern version of the the most
occultic person he used a lot of magic
and sorcery and Hollywood's been
obsessed with this guy for a long time
he was on the Beatles cover there's a
lot of connections between modern-day
movies and his writing but he defined
the occult in like a sentence sure the
occult is really using supernatural
means magic spells sorcery and
specifically to get what you want in
this world a lot of what we heard from
Leah and her talking about the New Age
movement is really like the secret and
and you know really dealing with
thinking about yourself and how you
could manifest those things this is kind
of like that but with was sort of like
up a few notches kind of a thing you
know so he wrote a book called magic and
practice in theory listen to what he
says there are three main methods for
invoking any deity so you want to invoke
a God into your life
he said the third method is the dramatic
and perhaps the most attractive at all
certainly it is to the artists
temperament for it appeals to the
imagination through his aesthetic sense
let me put that in layman's terms for
if you want to invoke a spirit into your
life he's saying that one of the the
three great ways to do this is through
acting Wow interesting right no and it's
interesting that that Hollywood is very
into this guy Socrates you know he wrote
a lot about the muse what does it move
mused you know an inspiration right
inspiration yeah what gives you your
inspiration and this is what he says in
like manner the muse first of all
inspires men are self because they are
inspired and possessed they are simply
inspired to utter that which the muezzin
tells them to to to do and you talked a
little bit about this on on the show you
know it's like you know you've got these
voices that are talking to you and
inspiring you to do this or to do that
right and kind of showing you a
slideshow of some new thing or whatever
you know right right so Socrates is
saying the same thing for not by art or
by knowledge do you say what you say but
by possession Wow whoa which is kind of
an interesting interesting idea that he
was bringing out this came from a book
called actors on acting now I'm gonna go
over some history okay so this this this
you may or may not have ever heard of
these these these kind of actors these
are well before year guys is time and
well before ours actually contrary to
maybe your belief have you ever heard of
Rudolph Valentino Rudolph Valentino was
like the Brad Pitt of the 1920s you have
heard black and white bread okay you
know who Brad Pitt is this guy was
literally so immensely famous his movies
were all about like passion and love and
he would always get the girl and he was
like this lady's man right and when
Rudolph Valentino would go out in public
people were so obsessed with him that
there was these crowds that would form
around him and then he often had to have
walk around with police officers because
it was like riots would almost happen
right this guy was immensely immensely
famous but what people don't realize is
that actually the movies that Valentino
made were from his wife Natasha who was
a huge spiritualist so listen to this
quote
every night Valentino's wife Natasha
would hold a seance calling forth for
the spirit world to help her inner
creative undertaking they would with a
pen and paper in hand she would go into
a trance and she would start writing
okay
after the outpourings were typed out
they were brought to the set the next
day and given to the director and that's
the what the movies that were made good
so if you go on YouTube and you look at
the movies that Valentino made those
scripts are were completely handed from
the demonic world Wow a script written
in a day by automatic writing and you
know the human mind can't even make that
happen but these demons have already had
it planned out who are we gonna who's
gonna allow us to write through them you
know right and sort of like a team who
does that remind you of in a sports
world where the wife is like doing these
spiritual oh my goodness Brady yes any
superstitions going into the game any
special thing you carried into the game
on Sunday that you had ducked away
somewhere I did I always sung you know
I've learned a lot from my wife over the
years she's so much about the power of
intention you know and believing things
that are really gonna happen and she
always makes a little altar for me at
the game because she just wills it so
much and so she put together a little
altar for me that I could bring with
pictures of my kids and I have these
little special stones and healing stones
and protection stones is she as we were
necklace and take these drops she makes
I say all these mantras
and I stopped questioning her a long
time ago I did I just shut up and listen
and at first I was like this is kind of
crazy and then about four years ago we
were playing the Seahawks and she said
you better listen to me this is your
year but this is all the things you're
gonna have to do to win and I did all
those things and by god you don't work
there's pretty good and then in 2015 it
was about early January and she said you
know how much I love you and I said yeah
and she said I just want to let you know
this is not gonna be your year and of
course we lost I said what a 16 look
like yeah
and she said 16 is gonna be your year so
it was early January this year and I
said they by asking like do we have a
chance and she said yeah but you're
gonna do a lot of work and you're really
gonna have to listen to me so man I
listened to her and right after the game
she said see I did a lot of work you do
your work I do mind
she said you're lucky you married a wig
I'm just a good witch topper amazing
wife Giselle is that her name yeah she
was the Victoria's Secret model who is a
witch yeah yeah yeah so yes this stuff
still happens today so Mae West you
heard of Mae West come on soon as
sometimes like these cartoons would
saying stuff like that's funny no yeah
that's actually really impressive you
heard of me West nope never heard of me
with Wow
okay we're not gonna dress here too long
my mom is so proud so so listen to this
this is Mae West ringer 1930s motion
pictures are one of the mainstays of the
Great Depression and attendance to movie
theaters skyrocket
I'm no angel movie star Mae West was
also known as the queen of sex and the
statue of libido her work helped the top
of the biblical sexual boundaries that
were deeply embedded in the people of
the early 20th century she could have a
romance for somebody outside of wedlock
I'm a man my life it was pretty raw I
don't know how many about mate was
pretty raunchy for that era what I'm
good I'm very good but when I'm bad I'm
better no star had greater impact in the
long run and they was Mae West was a
one-woman sexual revolution so here's
what's going on here America you have to
understand the history of our country
like we are rooted in Christianity this
country had a lot of like you know
person value Christian values Christian
morals during this era it was there was
a lot of the stuff that we see today I
mean our media has totally tamed and we
got some pretty like evil stuff out
there but that just wasn't really the
case and here comes along Mae West which
toppled over the biblical understanding
of sex inside of a marriage right so
let's listen to this this is Mae West's
psychic okay
his name was Kenny Kingston and he's
reflecting back on Mae West in her life
when she was upset that no one had been
able to come up with a script idea she
would walk about her room saying forces
forces please come and help me with this
script you talked about this I would do
this kind of stuff all the time right I
would say you know help me with this
path help me with this thing that I'm
trying to do and I used to do automatic
writing and when you actually invite the
spirits in so it said did you ever
actually have experience of that yeah
Wow like I would be trying to figure out
you know what my next steps were and I
would ask for guidance and then I would
just start writing and I would automatic
writing
would you feel your hand actually moving
or is it just like whatever was coming
out it's more just like whatever it
comes out of your mind you just start
writing stuff down and then
all of a sudden you have all these ideas
you're in it starts to make sense
Wow good you feel like they were your
own or you knew exactly where they were
coming I felt like I knew I was getting
guidance I was quitting talking about
that download knowledge right then yeah
download would be different it's more
auditory where the they're writing you
just it just flows Wow so she would get
these forces to come in to her and help
her write a script and then this is what
would happen she would begin to hear the
voices images the plot was revealed to
her she would summon the stenographers
and tell them to work around the clock
and she would lie in bed in a
trance-like state dictating as the
spirits entered her and she would write
the scripts and hand those to the
director and that's what they'd make
this is this is way back when we don't
even get into the modern age yet right
so you look at Mae West's and the movies
that she made remember she mentioned
earlier I am no angel right or she has
like the six sexes at the sin say tional
Mae West
so you these are these are topics that
we look at today we don't even bat an
eye because they're so used to sexual
bombardment right but this was racy
stuff back then when you think about it
it was like it's like the devil is
writing his Bible let's think of how the
Christian Bible was written John on the
Isle of Patmos getting these visions and
writings from our time today that is an
excellent point at least working through
people and really like I know this is
gonna sound really weird but the Bible
is a collection of a bunch of stories
and that's how we learn about God right
the devil has a collection of stories
Wow
in a visual format and that's how we
learn about a devil's world that's what
he's doing how about this character
Marilyn Monroe you know it's really
interesting there is really not a person
I have met yet no matter what age other
than you know somebody that's really
really little but if you're old enough
to like watch you know play a play on
the internet or watch TV then most
people have heard of Marilyn Monroe this
person is massively famous so here's a
little video clip with Marilyn Monroe
Monroe attributed her ability to affect
the public to other entities that would
inhabit her and
her over she was known for entering into
deep trances before each scene one of
Monroe's close personal psychics
recalled how she would draw attention
from the spirit world asking for their
guidance when she saw a camera any
camera she lit up and it was totally
different the moment the shot was over
she fell back into her not very
interesting position and I don't know
how to explain that
that's almost verbatim what Beyonce says
about I'm more reserved and I'm not very
interesting but when I'm Sasha I can
sing strong can I do us
Sasha is my alter ego
and when people see me sometimes I think
that when they meet me and they speak
with me
they're expecting Sasha and I'm really
kind of shy and not really shy but more
reserved and nothing like Sasha she can
do things that I cannot do when I'm in
rehearsal I mean I can try but then it
just doesn't happen
I can sing notes and sing strong and do
all these things that when I'm just by
myself I can't do the second that the
cameras turn on
she's someone else the second to turn
them off
she's totally someone else and he says I
can't explain that it's interesting how
they attach this man to these people
using the same spirit guide for the
previous person is yeah that was Kenny
Kingston yeah yeah yeah these guys are
around a lot of these dirty like you
know spiritualistic things that's why we
see so much of the New Age if the stuff
that's being written is coming from
these psychics and these people who are
communicating with spirits then what's
the message that we're getting when we
sit in a dark room and stare at a
blinking light right listen to what
Marilyn Monroe says Jacqueline Hyde I'm
more than - I'm so many people they
shock me sometimes I wish it was just me
hmm she was tormented by the voices that
she heard in her head all the
communication and I can relate to that
you know you get to a point where you
allow so much in your mind and it's like
who is the real mean it's like I'm just
trying to discover myself and then when
I come out of it you see you know all
these different thoughts and emotions
that would come over you that they
weren't me yeah and it gets exhausting
right and if you're opening up your
chakras you're opening up your third eye
you're opening your life to these these
spirits they're just coming and flowing
right into you and then it's like
confusing to you you know she was
tormented but that's just a devil being
in character so the devil comes to steal
kill and destroy but I come the Lord
comes to give a life and to give it more
abundantly
that's right yeah that's right how many
guys remember I Love Lucy yeah have you
ever seen the episodes no I haven't seen
that but I know you've never seen an
episode wow that's impressive
Wow Lucille Ball this title makes me
think
I love Lucifer you know Yeah right right
right Lucille Ball's her name so I think
that's where they came up the idea of
the show what's really interesting is um
she always had a particular phrase in
the show that she was it was a comedy
show about her and her husband and they
were always having these like funny like
problems and stuff and she was kind of
the wild one and her husband was always
trying to like clean up after her mess
and stuff like this she always had this
scene where she would say like something
would go wrong and she would be like
don't tell my husband don't you dare
yeah I'll tell him the truth don't you
dare and so she was always lying to her
husband but it was all wrapped in
laughter so it was like you kind of like
didn't want her to tell the husband
because she would get caught or whatever
like that so there's a lot of little
subtleties like that and what people
don't realize about Lucille Ball is she
was actually a film actress when she
started she wasn't a TV actress in fact
if you were a film actress and you were
to go down to the TV it was like taking
a step down these were the low people
like TV and and so everybody wondered
why did you go from the big screen to
all of a sudden becoming a TV actress
and it was because of this actress
Carole Lombard
and they and listen to this it was the
spirit of actress Carole Lombard who
guided Lucille Ball into taking a chance
on television and accepting the role to
star in this television show called I
Love Lucy now listen to this the
glamorous comedian who died in an
airplane crash in 1942 appeared to Lucy
in 1951 what's going on so this spirit
comes back and tells Lucille Ball
hey you should choose this job as going
and be in this television star and if
you do it you you will be famous now why
would the Spirit
of care that's a good point because
Satan has an agenda wants to propagate
his message yeah go all the way back to
what that what each one of the shows had
in it there was elements of lying you
know doing things deceitfully behind her
back but it was all wrapped in this
laughter and it's just breaking down the
moral code of everybody in society so
the devil's got time he goes back
further than that
teaser okay we're actually planning on
making a documentary about this but you
go way back and look at how technology
was developed a lot of these scientists
guys they were into some of them would
go to seances every night mm-hmm and you
know a lot of them admit that the
spirits offered to help them and assist
them in their work I always tell people
ask yourself this question why does this
spirit want to help develop technology
Yeah right
especially mass media yeah because it's
a teaching tool yeah and I think like
the laugh track thing that's a form of
brainwashing because like you're
watching something and you see something
that you know is wrong but now you hear
an audience laughing you know haha you
let your guard down I mean that's how a
lot of stuff becomes normalized you know
even like the homosexuality movement you
know you had willing Grace and the real
flamboyant guy hey and the laughter and
they bring introduced it with comedy and
then subtly now you got to the point
where you know there's a kid on the
Disney Channel who's like I'm gay and
you know he's like part of the main
story and and there's like this this
conflict or like where you're feeling
sympathetic and stuff and not to say we
shouldn't feel sympathetic for people in
general but it's just the fact that how
they introduce this lifestyle to make it
normalized through laughter we've come
so far that the Disney Channel has put
out things like The Descendants where
it's like these are the evil kids of
them evil villains and all the stories
and they're just misunderstood you know
that's the idea it's like so the devil
started back here with a Christian
nation that really had these values and
he slowly chipped away at the
until he's able to just literally handle
their normal whatever and we're like I
eat it up like we're the evil characters
we want them to win you know and that's
where he's going with all of it he hates
what we're doing right now yeah
supposing is less so let's talk a little
bit about this in a modern setting
because you know we've we've analyzed on
this show superheroes you saw the one
that we did on Marvel right so you see
kind of like some of the stuff behind
what's going on in those stories so
we're jumping into our generation now
we're jumping up to our generation so
I'm leading you into some actors and
actresses that you guys might be
familiar with this this particular
gentleman his name is Alan Moore that
we're gonna talk about he was a comic
book writer he's written for he's
written from he'll Swamp Thing Watchmen
V for Vendetta these any things that you
guys have heard of yeah okay so I'm
gonna show you a clip of Alan Moore and
what he really is into he follows this
snake God interesting that it's a snake
God called glycon and glycon is where he
gets a lot of his inspiration from a
listen to this what's it for you that's
flowing like on I believe that every
single individual human being should
probably make their own peace with the
universe
I mean we're all of us different
emotionally we're all different
physically until actually it would be
really odd if we were all the same
spiritually so I mean that's more I have
a problem with religion per se because
religion the very word it comes from the
same root word as ligature and ligament
and it means to be bound together in one
belief which are found a bit creepy and
a bit unnatural you can't have that
conversation with a Christian
fundamentalist
yeah the ecology of what we called
fundamentalism these days is basically
entirely based upon nineteen thirty's
tensho revivalism right it goes back no
further learning about 80 years and yet
it's a very frightening and dangerous
mindset because I mean as far as I
understand it at the moment
there are genuine worries that it
certainly in America that this could
actually in the gate silence yeah
who dragged us back into a new Dark Ages
anybody got any thoughts on what he said
there it all sounds great right
it all sounds great that's something
that I would have totally resonated with
like how could we all be the same how
can we all have the same beliefs you
know we're different people but we're
different in the kingdom of God and we
all have our own things to bring to the
table and we can have a relationship
with the creator that's what it's about
and that's what he wants for us and this
is just it's become so lonely you're
just kind of figuring it all out and
you're getting help and guidance from
these beings but there's no basis
there's no truth do you hear the kind of
New Age philosophy that he's saying oh
yeah because it's like have any belief
that you want just not which one right
fundamentalist Christianity that one's
wrong but everything else is okay mm-hmm
that seems to be what I'm hearing with
the whole New Age movement as well is
it's literally like there's all these
different paths all over here except for
that one path right here is gonna keep
you in the darkness and that's called
Christianity you know Alan Moore when he
actually was I think he was turning 40
years old he he threw a party and he all
of a sudden wanted to do something kind
of wild and so he decided that he was
going to become possessed at the party
and he decided that he was going to
become this magician and so all of a
sudden it was like a lightning bolt hit
him of things got a bit strange he says
and after looking back he was probably
in some sort of borderline schizophrenic
state he found himself seemingly in
conversation with some sort of entity
its presence surrounded his head moving
and speaking lucidly to him and he said
he was very spaced out God struck you
Babel for a while like an idiot but I
must have been unbearable for two or
three months and now I've integrated
that into the rest of my life
okay British yeah so here's what's
happening
he's now incorporating this into his
writing so when he sits down and he
writes those comic books he's asking
those spirits to help him in that
writing and whatever he's written in
that is with the movies that there
and when you go to the theater and you
see any movie from this man right here
why are you watching you're watching the
very thoughts that the demons want the
world to know
Wow it's interesting to me the image
that it has behind him is very similar
to the image as you see for Kundalini
right right yeah exactly you know and
and and this is something that I pulled
from him so I mean he's very into this I
mean we covered this in the replacement
gods as well but there's a lot of
interviews with him and in the
documentary that we made and it goes
into much more depth he talks more about
this idea of tapping into the spirits
and all this kind of stuff
the writer do you remember the TV show
American are Six Feet Under
I've heard of it it was an HBO show and
it was like a bunch of guys that worked
at a mortuary right you've heard of the
movie American Beauty okay so True Blood
no these are kind of older but these are
things the the writer of this was very
much so into automative writing as well
how about Hugh Jackman and you guys know
who huge yeah yeah okay what was Hugh
Jackman known for Wolverine romantic
[Laughter]
alright so did you know that Hugh
Jackman what actually wasn't really like
thinking he was gonna be in a major
actor you know how he became to be an
actor sort of soul no but it's very
interesting he went on the BBC and he
was telling the backstory of how how he
actually got his first gig listen to
this it's interesting all your
platitudes to acting because you you're
a journalism student weren't you so I'm
still on home my journalism still on
hold I literally was just putting it off
so I took a few parts on classes and
worked at a gym and at the gym I met
this woman who this isn't a lie it
sounds like a made-up story but I was I
was actually joining her up and she was
looking at me and she just went is
everything all right she said you don't
understand I'm a white witch you've got
to get into acting immediately I said
well if you pass on classes funny you
should mention she said no no you're
gonna be a big star and I want you to
meet this woman penny
I said who's penny one who says she's an
agent well I met her and she's still my
agent and the day after I did an
audition and got landed a role on
neighbors the very next day he gets an
audition and books the role why would a
spirit literally talk through a medium
and tell him you need to go talk with
this lady over here and you will be
famous why aren't you picking him why
because he's willing to do what they
want you know what I think the spirit
world is paying attention they know you
know who's gonna be an agent of them or
who's not you know and they're there
they're literally directedness like god
is choosing people to go out and herald
his message as well you know the devil
is doing the same thing he's handpicking
I want this one I want this one and so
when we when we watch these movies we
often think like man that person got
lucky you know honey you hear stories
like this and it's like I don't know how
much luck is involved in this right yeah
these guys are literally being
handpicked by the other side why because
they're the preachers and pastors
they're the evangelists of Satan's
messages and they're often like the most
attractive people you know like the
beautiful people are in Hollywood
because Satan wants to pick a good
representative somebody that people look
they want to listen to and want to look
at and stuff and if they don't naturally
look like that they're very open to
doing whatever it takes to look like
that right now right you guys have heard
of Jeff Bridges yep yes he has won an
Oscar for a movie called crazy heart and
where he portrayed a singer and he's
being interviewed on on Good Morning
today and listen to the way that the
interviewer asks him how he's got into
his role and listen to the words that
she use and Entertainment Weekly writes
about you that you are generously
vain after so appealing in midlife
spread in other words you had Akane gain
some weight and kind of channel this
kind of sadness really yeah it's very
powerful way you do it because it's
about a guy who redeems himself who
finds basically redemption who are you
channeling were you channeling
Kristofferson we chat Johnny Cash played
so many extraordinary women that
basically I'm getting mistaken for one
I'm very clear about the fact that I'm
the vessel for other people's stories
and other women's lives I try to allow
the spirit of the character to live
through me so I just try to encompass
and allow myself I'm almost the vehicle
to channel the spirit of the character
at the root so this is this is literally
a very common thing that's about acting
I took acting classes when I was in Los
Angeles and you know it's very
interesting because the classes that
teach you the real methods of acting is
basically to empty yourself of who you
are so you can allow this other
character to come in and and flow
through you you can see that the the New
Age philosophy there right and and and
why so many of these actors are kind of
caught into this whether they know it or
not but it's like literally the same
language is what we heard you talking
about and in your higher-self that's
right you know higher self is a big
thing you want to anchor your higher
self so you have to kind of yeah
meditate clear your mind and then your
higher self can come in and live the
life of your dreams and letting other
lives from these people that you're
playing come out in you right so of a
question is there any is there such
thing as fiction if they're channeling
these spirits or if they're trying to
act out this thing if it's fiction I
mean it's never been like this no person
to attach it to so how does that work
you know I don't know like in that in
that movie with deaf bridges in the
movie with Jeff Bridges basically he was
saying that she was asking him did you
did you channel Johnny Cash they said
yeah a bit of that and a bit of the
other actor that
she mentioned so I think they're using
these other actors as inspiration even
though it's about a fake character and I
mean it's like not necessarily about one
person's life but they're saying like
Johnny Cash kind of lived this life so
I'm gonna use his spirit to play this
part
Spike Lee you're familiar with Spike Lee
you ever heard of a movie called Malcolm
X oh yeah okay historical movie about
Malcolm X right in fact when you watch
the movie the words that they used were
literally taken verbatim from Malcolm
X's speeches Denzel Washington was one
of the actors that was in there
incredible job
yeah it did an incredible job and so
Spike Lee is sitting here having a
conversation with downsell Washington
and they're talking about this one
specific scene where Denzel continued on
past the script listen to what he says
one day out there and you just you
channel the spirit of Malcolm because I
remember one specific time where you
know we went to knock more speeches and
once you finish for the text you kept on
going right we kept blowing the cap we
kept loading camera and there were many
times in that film where we all had the
pinch of salt because we thought we saw
the reincarnation wearing right now
it wasn't about impersonation right you
know how to capture the spirit and the
spirit and just trying to you know act
is what I'm gonna look like him and that
but that were that's his surface though
mmm so check this out this is just his
conversation with Denzel so Spike Lee
and Denzel start talking about other
actors and other movies and Denzel gets
a phone call from Will Smith because he
was going to play Ollie and so he wanted
to prepare for the role listen to the
advice
that Denzel Washington gives it the
circus stuff
Will Smith called me before he started
Ollie and he was saying what should I do
you know and he did the boys for me and
he had it I said I think you should go
to Michigan and play with Holly when I
did Malcolm X I would just pray every
morning you know before I came in that
drill I'm like Malcolm come on you know
because it's not for me
right you know it's just this pavement
for those oh wow this is my goal and as
them saying it dude come on Malcolm come
into me so I can act this dude these
spirits are messing with these guys a
good place yeah he's wanting to
represent whom and represent the culture
and the best way he can and it's just
but he's praying to something inviting
that is created in I like that to
something so it's not actually Malcolm
right yeah he's good yeah and he's
giving advice to another actor saying
the same thing though Oscar
award-winning actor Denzel Washington
told 60 minutes exactly how he brings
forth his best performances basically
what I did was got on my knees and sort
of communicated with the spirits and
when I came out I was in charge powerful
soon powerful scene it would I couldn't
have acted that I couldn't have written
that down and made a decision to play
that so so going back to this
conversation where he's having with
Pharrell Williams listen to this Spike
Lee's telling Pharrell about this this
experience as well it's like you're
writing a treatment I finally called cut
I called in said Denzel where did that
come from I mean you went on five
minutes after what was scripted to spike
I don't know five minutes he rolled
beyond the script and I even saw another
interview with Spike Lee and I'll see if
I can find it where he was literally
like reading the script and he was just
like it's not even on the script and
then he's pulling up on his phone and
stuff like this and reading the real
speech and Denzel is spitting off the
real speech word-for-word
that's the thing they're inviting these
spirits in and then would like it's
inside of you
when they decide when when they come in
with and any and he's like sitting there
going - hey hey hey didn't sell like
where'd you get on and he's like I don't
know you know I mean something's going
on under the surface here that's pretty
wild
so listen to this you guys heard of Jack
Nicholson yes okay so do you know who
Shirley MacLaine is Shirley MacLaine is
one of the one of the actresses that was
hugely involved in the New Age movement
okay okay so she's at the AFI which is
like American Film Institute Awards show
or whatever and they are honoring
Shirley MacLaine and she's telling where
she gets her inspiration from and she's
talking about this one scene that she
did with Jack Nicholson listen to what
she says when people asked me who is my
role model in this business I say you
jack I think why you're my role model
has to do with the way you relate to
vanity or the lack of it I mean I have
to tell you I just adore the fact that
you don't care how you look I adore how
you commit to the part you don't care
about your little bald spot you don't
care about your stomach remember that
wonderful stomach
you don't care about your wrinkles this
is all extremely important to me doing a
love scene with with with Jack Nicholson
is absolute middle aged bliss I mean to
lie in bed and rehearse a love scene
it's so funny it's so spontaneous it's
so open we're lying in bed and we're
rehearsing the astronaut Garrett
Breedlove scene he's explaining to
Aurora of what it was like to walk on
the moon she's loving it and then we
launched into the first take and two
voices came out of you do you remember
this two voices and they were they were
simultaneous words but they were two
levels of sound and I looked over at you
you were amazed I was amazing you said
well sure sure I'm many different people
I said no Jack you're channeling so they
all know exactly what she's talking
about
that's right voices simultaneously you
kinda I couldn't drive that you cannot
produce that textbook demonic possession
heard of that before
that doesn't even feel a new age and
what I saw that seems like straight
demonic right right these guys are
literally tapping into this
spiritualistic world to help them
undertake these crazy rules that's why I
really honestly believe you see a
performance from a particular actor and
it is powerful you're just like that
wood that was so amazing but you think
man there's some demonic forces working
through these people that they were they
were alive when Malcolm X was there they
that demon probably saw firsthand the
way Malcolm X acted and he's acting
through you know Denzel and and and
going for that how about this particular
actor you guys recognize him yeah yes
yeah we played this on one of our other
shows but I wanted to show you just for
just for this case so but he was
preparing for Ghost Writer
this is what he did to prepare for his
role you
an acting discipline that you've
referred to as a new version manicures
right that correct yeah what are the
core principles I've been told that all
actors really hail from the early
medicine men and the shamans in the
villages pre Christianity where they
would put on masks and and act out and
and really what they were probably
pretty crazy but they would go in and
find answers to questions today you're
called psychotic if you do that but it's
all dove it's all semantics so what I
would do is I put on afro-caribbean
paint like a white and black paint and
black out my eyes so I look like this
sort of afro-caribbean voodoo icon and
then I would sew in bits of Egyptian
artifacts that were thousands of years
old into my costume and gather some onyx
are tourmaline or something that was
meant to have vibrations and who knows
if it works or doesn't but for me it was
an idea of like trying to stimulate my
my mind or trick my mind into believing
I was this this character from another
dimension and I would walk on the set
and then wouldn't speak to anybody
wouldn't say award so I projected this
aura of horror which created fear of my
fellow actors which then inspired me to
believe I really was this character I
think I'd love to be on set with you
yeah thanks feeding off of the lattice
here what you think of also he's taking
real shamanic artifacts putting on them
you don't see that in the movie you
don't know that something's sewn into
the inside of his thing and I think that
all these things like you know there's a
reason why you can be demonically
tortured like have you ever actually
been tortured any of you guys and you
have it any demonic spirits or anything
kind of like mess with you a little bit
oh yeah yeah was it something that you
potentially had in your home that
allowed them access to you I mean how
did how did they get into your realm and
are able to even interact with you and
why don't they just interact with
everyone I think that literally we give
them access through various different
ings in fact there's a guy named John
Todd who really was big with with the
music industry worked at Capitol Records
and they would pray that the demons
would go with every single
record out and he says oh you want to
know how many demons are in your home go
count your records and that was
literally like they knew that the
spirits could follow those records and
then that gave them access into your
home I thought all I had all these
channeled books I got rid of all of them
I threw them all in the recycling bin
yeah yes I mean it's why we're so hard
on Disney and stuff right now all the
magic in sorcery and all that kind of
stuff that cuz of Disney because I
believe that it gives the demons access
just like he's talking about I put these
like you know sorceress types of things
in my body and then all of a sudden now
I can act this type of particular way
right so you guys you guys know Robin
Williams he often was very tortured as a
comedian you know heard lots of things
in his life I've seen interviews with
him like talking about all these like
voices that he would hear in his head
and he was asked by Us Weekly you know
what
what is his process how is his acting
and he said it's literally like
possession all of a sudden you're in and
you get this energy and it starts going
and later on in the article he says but
there is also this thing it is
possession in the olden days you'd have
been burned for it but there's something
empowering about it I mean it's a place
where you can be a dr. Jekyll or mr.
Hyde
where you can actually become this other
force so he was explaining that acting
to him was literally like having
something come in take possession over
you and you know we celebrate it in our
world whereas in the olden days you'd
have been burned or why they were
burning people I mean I'm not for them
burning people but you ever wonder why
like what they were trying to protect
society from yeah you know I mean I
think that demonic possession has always
been a fearful thing and you think of
today look the venom movie that comes
out right it's like now now the guy
that's possessed by this crazy evil
thing is like the hero
what is this taking Old Testament
principles and I'm you know using them
for the modern time because you look
back in the Old Testament it's like if
there's a witch among you okay yeah
they're out the candy good stuff I know
so they're just doing the modern
equivalent and Bernina more drowning
yeah but it's it's not even I don't
think they'd see it as a demonic spirit
that they're entering I think that they
see it as like a force an energetic
force of the universe that we can use
freely so it makes it feel and sound
safe for people excellent point because
I see that as the same deception that
happens in the New Age right
it's the demonic world that's literally
communicating with you and tinkering
with you but they give it this like it's
this energy and it's this whatever orb
and to the actor it's just well it's my
process of how I get involved in this
right I don't think some of them I mean
maybe some of them do I don't think some
of them really understand what's
happening like I didn't right I didn't
understand what was happening right and
I think that's why it it is a deception
the you know if possible the devil will
try to deceive the very elect you know
that's his mesh method when Leonardo
DiCaprio was in a movie called total
eclipse the director and ESCO Holland
said this about Leo Leo is like a medium
he opens his body in his mind to receive
messages coming from another person's
life a totally different director when
he was in Romeo and Juliet's Baz
Luhrmann says this about Leo
with Leo you might see thirty people
come out of him in one day Wow
and you think like have you seen a
Leonardo DiCaprio movie yeah all of us
from the message that yeah that act that
demonic world is wanting us to learn how
about Keanu Reeves Keanu is a very
complex guy with lots of demons into him
I was trying to tap into that and
utilize that says director Taylor
Hackford from devil's advocate Wow
openly admitting these guys have demons
John there's some kind of conspiracy
behind Leonardo DiCaprio not getting an
Oscar till recently after all the
Magnificent projects he's done I don't
know I don't know I mean it's
interesting some actors like Johnny Depp
the same sort of thing he's been in all
these amazing movies yet he's I don't
think ever won an Oscar mmm
it's interested in because the one
director said you know thirty different
people and here you have done it Johnny
Depp saying I'm thirty different people
right anyway the Legion was or something
Allegiant I think is thousands but yeah
yeah but isn't that kind of interesting
Johnny Depp
old vanity fair' I know I have demons
and I don't know if I want to get rid of
them altogether I would like to
experience them in it I'm trying to
understand myself and they're dealing
with thirty-plus themselves think about
the little voices that you have to hear
and that's why I think you see Jim
Carrey literally he cracked his mind
he's emptied himself so many times he's
become so many different people that
it's like he lost who Jim Carrey was
Heath Ledger listen to what the Los
Angeles Times reported Heath Ledger's
creepy performance seems to have
summoned up demons no one could imagine
accessible to him like this in Los
Angeles times they're not like literally
going oh yeah you know there's the
spiritual war going on there they're
like literally like yeah this guy had
access to demons that other people
normally don't
speaking of Jack Nicholson when Heath
Ledger died of whatever suicide drug
overdose whatever it was these people
ran up to Jack Nicholson and told him
that he had died and he actually said I
warned him because Jack Nicholson was
the first Joker and he said that he
warned Heath Ledger not to do that part
that's right because these guys are
invoking spirits and they often can't
get rid of him and I believe he evokes a
spirit called Osmo Dias and when he got
Osmo Dias into him it made him go insane
and he was eating you know sleeping
pills like it was going out of style
and couldn't couldn't ever get peace so
how about Marlon Brando I heard oh yeah
he said something really interesting
about acting listen to what he says
about it what are you down great acting
is a profession don't you know you've
said over the years it's not a fake
profession for a man people lie
constantly every day by not saying
something that they think or saying
something that they don't think or
showing something that they don't feel
or kind of give the appearance of
feeling something that they don't don't
actually I said that did not yeah but
that's not acting that is acting so
Marlon Brando describes acting is a lie
right so it's kind of interesting about
this he actually got into a lot of
trouble with this particular interview
right here in fact the acting business
was pretty upset at him to be like you
know why are you calling acting a lie
and so Johnny Depp was then
interviewed by Larry King and this is
many years later Johnny Depp is a real
big fan of Marlon Brando and so the
topic comes up of what Marlon Brando
said about acting listen to how a Johnny
Depp answers this it is a weird
profession as Marlon said he had Marlon
had the best definition of acting that
that exists you know it's a strange job
for a grown man
and that's dude like it it's a strange
job for a grown man that's the right but
he called something else the people in
the business that mad at he said it on
our show he called it lying for a living
right most actors say they're not lying
hmm did you think that was an unfair
expression I think it's totally I think
it's totally right yeah it's lying it is
lying why wouldn't it be you can make it
lying you can make it not lying if you
know it's you can find your own truth
but it's still a lie you know the man
you're gonna go to the craft service
table you're not having the aids man
know it so you're gonna have some Fritos
or whatever man you know right you know
he's not gonna like eat a giant chicken
leg and chuck it somewhere and such
screaming winch right so even Johnny
Depp goes listen let's call it what it
is yeah you are lying for a living
Shia LeBouf you guys know who this actor
is yes he's kind of what an actor that's
that's in our modern world here this is
what he told USA Today acting is a con
at the end of the day you lie for a
living
you're deceitful and that is my goal to
be the best possible liar oh very
interesting so if you kind of see a
pattern here these spirits are literally
working through a lot of these actors
and it's so crazy in this business where
they are pretending to be something that
they're not and it's like all of this
together is really pushing messages out
into the world and that's where when we
analyze things like the Marvel Universe
or whatever you see the spiritual world
flipped upside down because the spirits
are literally wanting to give you
alternate in
and that's kind of like what I see with
the whole New Age movement it's like
they're presenting almost the facts
they're just a little bit twisted around
to the other side Anton LaVey do you
guys know who this is
yes okay the guy who started the Church
of Satan listen to this quote television
is the major mainstream infiltration for
the new satanic religion he even goes on
to say the TV set or satanic family
altar has grown more elaborate since the
1950s and from a tiny little fuzzy
screen to huge entertainment centers
covering entire walls with several TV
monitors what did he call the TV set
this satanic family altar I think he
even said that you know now homes have
like like a steeple it's the antenna
like a church yeah yeah so I want to end
with this we know of this place in
Hollywood called
Hollywood right and the history of it
really it was it was called Hollywood
land there was actually the word land on
the end of the word and over the years
they dropped the word land and it was
just called Hollywood but do you know
what the Holly is comes from a plant
comes from a plant it's a Hollywood
right Holly it is a sacred wood that
which is used to make the wands that put
people to sleep and they would make
these potions and that's what that's
what it would put people to sleep so I
find it very ironic let's just say that
the very place that is that is spewing
all this information out to the world is
literally this this Holly land that
Hollywood that is literally putting
people spiritually to sleep and they
hire the best liars that's right that's
right
well then even in the New Age though a
lot of people talk about not watching
television I think it puts people in a
trance asleep interesting and they want
people to be spiritually awake and
involved in the spiritual aspects
interesting so that's a whole that's
another yeah that's kind of even another
complicated situation because it's like
they realize the power of it so they
don't want you to do it that's what
always kind of tripped me out about like
really heavy metal bands that were
vegan I mean like I was just like what
do you care you're you're in these like
really crazy environments yet you don't
need me like what's the do a lot of
those hardcore bands are a
straight-edged yes no drugs they're
animal activists I know that yeah
there's some of you animal life over
even human life yeah yeah you guys
member outcasts the band yeah hmmm
outcasts I think one of their songs they
said no drugs or alcohol so I can get
the message clear like they understood
that that would been um their ability to
communicate and perhaps that's why you
know the New Age movement doesn't want
that those are ambassadors for the New
Age so they don't want you ssam beat out
like the rest of the world they want you
promoting your thing empowered and
sharing with others and yeah the more
you share the more they give you yeah
that's why these actors are elevated
that's right
because they're making such an impact
let's give them all their fame and their
money and make their life really
comfortable that's right okay I want to
share two verses with you we've read
this verse many many times Deuteronomy
18 10 through 12 there shall not be
found among you anyone that maketh this
son or daughter pass through the fire or
use it divination or observer of times
or an enchanter or witch or a charmer or
can or a consultor with familiar spirits
a wizard a necromancer for all that do
these things are an abomination to the
Lord when the Bible uses that word
abomination it means God hates these
things and so God hates magic sorcery
anything that's gonna talk to familiar
spirits and like you had mentioned
earlier in that last episode that the
spirits felt familiar to you they did
you know like something like like they
would come back in the same way and
there's definitely a reason why the
Bible uses very strong language not to
do that also familiar like a dead loved
one or actor or whatever that's right
says in Leviticus 20 verse 6 the soul
that turneth after such that have
familiar spirits and after wizards and
goes a whoring after them i will set my
face against that soul and will cut him
off from amongst his people i think the
worst thing that you could hear out of
you know with your ears is literally god
saying i'm
turn my face away from evening God is
very patient he's very long suffering
and and for me to read these words and
realize there is a point past God's
forbearance is is it is an alarming
thing and why is that I believe that
because it is so dangerous he can
legally lead you away to the point where
you can you know go well beyond you know
God's well not well beyond God's reach
because he can reach anyone clearly that
was her testimony as well but mm-hmm and
he's seeking to protect he's seeking to
show his love and if you directly
against that you've made your choice and
he'll respect that choice but then he
has those you know people to protect
from these forces that's right yeah and
they're saying like if you love me let
me go or something like tough love time
like God's loves you so much all right
I'm gonna give you over to this thing
that you just keep going after you know
I've tried over and over and light and
darkness can't coexist yeah so I
actually have a lot more slides on here
but I'll tell you what I'm gonna save it
for the post show okay that's all right
with you guys
so if you guys want to see the rest of
this and we got a couple of those little
clips and and we really want to continue
forward with why is it so so much coming
out of our ministry to be careful what
you let in front of your eyes which you
let in front of your mind which you get
yourself involved in why we feel so
passionate about this is really because
we have seen the evidence of where this
actually can lead a soul and so thank
you for watching if you you know
somebody that would benefit from this
kind of a message here why don't you
share it you know post a link on
Facebook or email it to some of your
friends and of course we want to hear
your comments thank you so much for
tuning in Thank You Leah for joining us
and
coming on for a couple of shows and we
hope to see you guys next Friday thank
you
[Music]